[Musique]
c'est un ballet diplomatique incessants
qui ne porte pas encore ses fruits
la france l'egypte et la jordanie ont
déposé 7 me au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu une nouvelle proposition de
résolution afin de demander un cessez le
feu entre israël et gaza
nous avons souhaité et l'union
européenne le manifestera de travailler
en lien avec le secrétaire général des
nations unies pour faire en sorte qu'au
sein du conseil de sécurité on puisse
très rapidement acter cette volonté
commune d'un cessez le feu le plus
rapidement possible ouvrant la voie à ce
moment là en suite à une relance du
processus de paix une proposition
soutenue par la chine et la russie mais
qui doit encore convaincre les états
unis washington a déjà refusé par trois
fois des déclarations similaires soumise
par pékin oslo est tunis un soutien
indéfectible à israël qui irrite
profondément les palestiniens sans
hénaff est trop c'est trop
je peux vous dire que la responsabilité
immédiate de la communauté
internationale et d'instaurer un cessez
le feu immédiat à des 16 boîtes noires
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
un acte honteux du conseil de sécurité
qui ne parvient pas à exprimer de
position unifiée appelant à la fin de
cette agression à gré sur place en
israël et dans les territoires
palestiniens
la tension ne diminue pas cette nuit les
bombardements israéliens ont encore
répondu au roquettes du hamas
hier les affrontements parfois
meurtriers se sont multipliées en
cisjordanie entre forces de sécurité et
manifestants palestiniens à l'occasion
d'une grève générale en soutien à gaza
de son côté le premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou ne semble
pas souhaiter d'accalmie le hamas le
hamas et le djihad islamique ont reçu
d'écho kelly ne s'attendait pas nous
avons ramené le hamas des années en
arrière
madame sûr nous continuerons aussi
longtemps que nécessaire pour ramener le
calme aux citoyens d'israël une crise
sécuritaire qui s'ajoute au risque de
crise humanitaire selon l'onu
soixante douze mille palestiniens ont
été déplacés et 2500 ont perdu leur
maison depuis le début du conflit
plus de 200 personnes ont perdu la vie
et des milliers ont été blessées